we built a society where we're told to
go to a college find someone we love
work a job for 50 years when we're gonna
live happily ever after
but it doesn't happen we don't
necessarily feel it you guys actually
set us up for success
[Music]
can I have my Millennials stand in the
right pool of light and my baby lures on
the left full of light when it comes to
jobs you should do what you love
I'm going to say hell yes do what you
love that's like if you don't love it
you won't do a good job then you quit
and bring a copy down ecstatic sadder I
agree I mean I've tried to put myself in
a position to stay away from things that
I don't like I hated going to school so
I left and I can how powerful that was
I'm the CEO and founder of tens ot I
went to UCLA hated going to school so I
dropped out after three years and you
have an entrepreneur it just occurred to
me though I wonder if whoo you know
maybe we're all fortunate enough that we
can because not everybody gets to just
do what they love maybe circumstances
don't allow that depending you know I'm
just fortunate I was brought up in a
family that allowed me to explore
options and paid for me to go to college
and even though we all agree that you
should do what you love yeah I agree
with you completely and I went through
my mind but I think that it's important
at least for me to say everyone should
be able to do what they love and to have
that be an expectation for everyone and
not have it be an expectation okay well
you know if you have challenges in your
life then you'll never be able to do
what you love we had a Japanese
restaurant growing up and I cooked
tempura you know did my homework and
took naps on the stacks of bags of rice
that we had in the back
did I love it no but we did it because
it was part of survival I did computer
science and I was a programmer for ten
years before I sided to pursue what I
really loved which was music so did luck
I don't agree with that statement
do you love all the jobs and I should be
your goal to do what you love don't you
think like whatever state you might have
to take steps to get to that but that's
what I worry about if we're gonna talk
about generational differences I own a
couple of businesses in Missouri and I
think sometimes the younger generation
doesn't get that part that just be to do
what you love sometimes you have to do
some things you hate to get there
Millennials don't work as hard as
previous generations
I live in southern Missouri
and I own a couple of businesses there
so I do think when I'm in LA I notice a
big difference so I think part of it is
a geographic thing you know I live in a
small town in the middle of nowhere
where you know people don't have role
models necessarily that are to look up
to that are are is motivated and it's
also really easy to get free stuff you
know low income housing food stamps and
disability or they'll come to me and say
well I can only work 25 hours a week
because if I work more than that I'm
gonna lose my low-income housing like I
said I think that's partly the society
where I live makes it too easy not to
work I think a baby boomer is somebody
who is taught to work hard and that if
you want something you have to figure
out how to go out and get it and don't
wait for somebody to hand it to you if
you try hard enough you can you can get
about anything you want I wasn't talking
about you guys so it all depends on who
you know and who you run into around me
there sure a lot of Millennials that are
working hard and I hear stories about
others who are lazy but isn't that the
truth in any generation absolutely I
work with the younger generation all the
time and so I I mean they come in 24/7
you know they're working very very hard
and I couldn't work without the younger
generation I wouldn't want to work the
younger generation I think Millennials
work harder than previous generations
for less safety nets and less structural
stability and I think you see people who
maybe they're not trying to go to work
as hard because they know that if they
try and they lose whatever assistance
they have or if they try to go to school
and they get in debt and they can never
pay it out or know that they can never
you know live in a place other than that
low-income housing unit then there's
like a lack of agency maybe to try but
also so many forces and then you know
you have all these companies that are
trying to get leaner and deliver on
short-term profits so they hire people
as contractors like all my friends are
contractors and they don't have health
insurance they don't have any of these
other things and
so like they've got to work harder so I
guess when I hear that about Millennials
and makes me upset just because I know
how hard my friends are working I think
the word millennial is often used to
portray a small slice of Millennials I
don't quite fit some of those
stereotypes but I don't think there's a
single stereotype either young people
today face harder challenges than any
previous generation I think the biggest
challenge facing young people day is the
environment and that we're growing up in
a world that is not being taken care of
and what that means for you know me and
my children if I have children what type
of world they're gonna be living in and
I just think it's not something we're
addressing at all I think the social
media makes it like I said it can be a
great tool but I also think it can make
life more difficult for people because
you can get offended or bullied or
relationships can be totally different
now because of you know people break up
with you over a text or whatever and I
think that's adds benefits with
challenges too that we didn't have as an
adult I find it hard compared to my
mother and her generation when it comes
to me trying to buy a house so when it
comes to me trying to save money because
I'm one of those contractor workers and
I do want a family and so is do I
continue doing what I love but do I did
go back into the low rat race and try to
get ahead and try to do X Y Z that's the
pressure that I face companies that
hired you for life and you had pension
you had that's all gone the world cost
of living is so high or if you live in a
place where it's not high then there are
no jobs you know I think it's harder for
you guys it's good to hear all your
points
I still think that we actually have it a
lot easier and I think the problem is
that we expect too much I don't think
that we should deserve to assume that
we're gonna get to immediately be able
to afford a house and I think that we
have a lot of things going for us and I
learned a lot of really valuable skills
completely for free you can join
Facebook groups and meet other
entrepreneurs doesn't cost any money you
can literally take classes at MIT and
Harvard for free and classes online yeah
and you guys didn't have that the access
information was in there I totally get
the financial and environmental
challenges so I think that we have the
resources to kind of solve them it's
important to you know want to have leave
each generation better than we found it
because if we lose sight of that then
you know what are we working for my
children will grow up in a better world
than I did
[ __ ] yeah absolutely
absolutely because I'll make sure that
yeah I think absolutely absolutely for
me I am determined when I do start my
family that they will have a better life
than what I've had I'm going to make
sure as a father as a provider that that
has to happen period point-blank I don't
have children but I'm speaking for
children in general even though I first
said life is harder for a younger
generation I think you're right and you
know health care is getting so much
better so much faster and then the
Internet has made so many more things
possible that I do think that young
people will grow up in an easier world
overall than we did I definitely agree
with a personal sentiment that we all
share but I do I do like think that one
of the things we didn't really have to
talk about was I like we don't
necessarily feel that the you guys
actually set us up for success
hmm like essentially we built a society
where we're told to go to a college find
someone we love and go buy a house and
work a job for 50 years when we're gonna
live happily ever after
but it doesn't happen I just don't get
like how you guys assumed that we were
gonna be able to do that exact same
thing no no I know I don't assume that
but what I do is that I put the work in
so when you put the work in and maybe
not universe a larger mindset of the
boomers is necessarily you know you guys
work like I did you got to be okay like
what I think the expectations are
changing like I everything you said
about the house of the marriage you know
I mean in my generation and that was my
job as a female was to catch a husband
that's what we went to college well
that's why women went to cut that's what
my college and I think your generation
has so many more opportunities and a
wider vision of what happiness can look
like and that it doesn't necessarily
mean you're gonna live in a house with a
picket fence and you're gonna have to
point to kids and they're gonna stay
interesting job forever I mean I think
you have so many more options available
to you some of that has shifted for you
so I hope at least it has I think that's
what I love about the younger generation
now is that they're working on
themselves first as supposed to fall in
love and
you know getting a guy that's gonna be
all well and good it's too late but I
think what we're saying is we've been
sewed up with creek without a paddle
well I'm a mom so I'm looking at the
future and I feel for you guys you know
who you're working hard which is great
but everything is getting more expensive
from the environment yes that is a
concern but one of the things that
really concerns me is a national debt
and we're borrowing and borrowing from
the future or kicking the can down the
road letting you guys and your kids and
your grandkids take care of it so I you
know I on behalf of our generation at
least on that aspect of life we're
really sorry where we are we're leaving
a big mess for you guys and I just pray
for you guys pray for our children I am
hopeful too I'm optimistic for our kids
but I'm also well aware of some troubles
that we're leaving our next generation
yeah but I will tell you this you will
survive it I don't want to survive you
are driven I want you can't be entitled
to anything we're not entitled we we
want what you got we want the what was
it the New Deal that Roosevelt settle
for so secure we want that too as I was
saying we want the basics of the
American Dream period
hey you guys what's up my name is Dan
and I'm Jason and thank you so much for
watching our episode we'd love to know
what you think in the comments also let
us know in the comments below what other
episodes you guys want to see from
middle ground we love hearing from you
guys hit subscribe watch more videos
[Music]